No transcript available for YouTube video: https://www.youtube.com/watch?v=5F5SEa7ak2E
Reason:
Could not retrieve a transcript for the video https://www.youtube.com/watch?v=5F5SEa7ak2E! This is most likely caused by:
No transcripts were found for any of the requested language codes: ('en',)
For this video (5F5SEa7ak2E) transcripts are available in the following languages:
(MANUALLY CREATED)
- zh-TW ("Chinese (Taiwan)")[TRANSLATABLE]
(GENERATED)
None
(TRANSLATION LANGUAGES)
- en ("English")
If you are sure that the described cause is not responsible for this error and that a transcript should be retrievable, please create an issue at https://github.com/jdepoix/youtube-transcript-api/issues. Please add which version of youtube_transcript_api you are using and provide the information needed to replicate the error. Also make sure that there are no open issues which already describe your problem!